it has been an horrific 24 hours
the hospital directors take me to see
soldiers injured on the eastern front
staff lieutenant andre was lacerated
with shrapnel he's heavily medicated but
says as soon as he's recovered he wants
to fight again
[Music]
[Music]
in another room vadim has just come out
of surgery he's in pain
dr alexey says he expects to see many
more blast injuries in
but it's unlikely any help will arrive
mario paul like the rest of the country
is besieged and on its own
the people here are exhausted they stay
inside unless they need supplies
but after years of fighting they're
inured to the sound of war
most don't even flinch when the shells
start flying
we're on the outskirts
of mario paul in the eastern district
the front lines are over in that
direction we've been listening to the
sound of a very heavy artillery battle
it's hard to say exactly how far it is
away but it sounds as though russian
forces are getting now much closer to
the city
and a sphere hovers over this place a
steady stream of evacuees are getting
out whilst they can
this man's putting his wife and daughter
on the train to safety before he goes
back in the army
many families will be separated in the
days to come
and with the russian invasion battering
every corner of this country there's no
doubt there will be many more tears
alex rossi sky news mario paul